what would the hero of your life's movie
do right now do that unless you're kind
and friendly and warm and loving you're
not going to enjoy this life you're just
not everyone encounters difficulties
there is no easy road it does not exist
oftentimes people make the mistake of
getting stuck and it is just a tactical
mistake here's an American comedian and
sports color commentator as a fan of
comedy he started his stand-up career in
1988 in the Boston area
in 2009 he began his podcast called the
Joe Rogan experience he's Joe Rogan and
here's my take on his top ten rules for
success rule number three is our
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end for some
special bonus clips also as joe is
talking if he says something that really
really resonates with you please leave
in the comments below what cool to Ronda
as well so other people can be inspired
as well enjoy
[Music]
be the hero of your own movie if your
life was a movie and it started now
forget about whatever financial
disasters you've had personal failures
relationship failures
what would the hero of your life's movie
do right now do that do those things we
define ourselves far too often by our
past failures we look at our past and we
say well that's me
that's not you you are this person right
now you're the person who's learned from
those failures and you can choose to be
the hero of your own movie right now
write down your goals write down things
you want to improve write down things
you won't tolerate from yourself write
down things you've done in the past you
never want to see yourself do again and
go forth from here as the hero of your
own movie build momentum build
confidence and momentum with each good
decision that you make from here on out
you can do it anyone can do it we
unique times we live in one of the
rarest times in human history where you
can choose almost all the input that
comes your way whether it's the movies
that you watch the books you read the
podcasts you listen to you can choose to
be inspired to that do that and be the
hero of your own it's good to treat
other people the way you would like to
be treated yourself it's like a golden
rule and there's a reason for and that
reason is that we're connected in some
strange way that we don't totally
understand unless you are good to other
people around you unless you're kind and
friendly and warm and loving you're not
going to enjoy this life you're just not
you're going to be problems everywhere
you go you're going to have problems
everywhere you go you got to figure out
a way to enjoy this life it's not
because of Jesus it's not because of
Moses it's not because of anybody that
may or may not have ever existed it's
because that's how you fit in better in
the world that's how you stay positive
and it doesn't have to be some it was
written 5000 years ago on animal skins
that doesn't have to be the Golden Rule
because it's old
you know that's dumb we need to figure
out like now today what what is you know
the best way to live your life what is
that you know there's got to be ways you
can be putting forward the most positive
energy I mean we know objectively what's
causing pollution we know objectively
what's causing birth defects and you
know and are we're taking in too much
chemicals and not enough vitamins we
know objectively all this stuff we know
how to organize our world and yet we
don't do it we know how to organize our
health and yet very few people do it we
know all these things the right path to
like being like a happy healthy person
is to do all that we already know you're
supposed to do take care of your body
take care of your health take care of
your mind your stress meditate be kind
to people we all know that you ask
anybody they know how to get by and to
be the the most evolved version of you
that you can be I mean it's not like a
magical checklist if you talk to people
but if you said okay here you got a
person you want to improve them what are
the things you're going to do to them
okay well if I was a life coach the
first thing I would say is this guy's
got to get on a diet that makes them
healthy I don't mean a diet just to lose
weight I mean just healthy foods in your
body
many many vegetables vegetables a lot of
a good quality protein a lot of water
stop the sodas stop the Bulls start
working out your body and get a better
sense of like how this machine feels
when it's moving it's flowing better
there's less tension in it your mind
feels like relaxed and you enjoy every
single moment of the day better step one
everybody knows that step right what
step two be cool to people be nice to as
many people as you can smile him as many
people as you can have them smile back
at you
tip well when you go to restaurants just
do the most you can be as nice as you
can you know and just still manage to
not have people walk all over you just
get through this life is nice in Japan
what else do what you want to do with
your life right don't don't go be doing
something you don't enjoy don't do
something that's don't get locked into
you know a car that you can't afford and
doing something crazy because you need
the money don't don't do that do what
you want to do do what the [ __ ] is it
that you really want to do because if
someone else is doing it you can do it
you know I mean everybody makes their
own path through this world but a lot of
people don't follow the path that they
really feel pulled to you know there's
for whatever reason they got negative
programming you know when they were kids
someone told them they couldn't do it or
told them to take the shortcut or or
take the the shore route that's a sad
thing man when you talk to dudes
especially like talented dudes and they
don't follow up with what they want to
do you know there's a bunch of people
that will say yeah well I'm family sure
you know it's a great idea for you to
just go out there and go crazy I have
people to support you need to listen
stop saying that stop saying any of
those things every single person who has
ever done anything worthwhile or
exceptional or difficult or
extraordinary anyone whether it's great
artists or authors or mathematicians or
whatever the it is everyone encounters
difficulties there is no easy road it
does not exist it is impossible everyone
has issues if you have time to pursue a
hobby if you have time to do anything in
your life you can better yourself and
here's one way you never better yourself
when you come up with excuses for why
other people are successful in your not
is dangerous when you give yourself an
escape yeah well that's easy for you to
say you know you do dude you didn't -
trust me everybody has a hard road I
wanted to jump out a window several
times during my young life I wanted to
jump in front of a train just end it
because too much pressure not really but
you know I'm saying theoretically we all
go through hard times we all go through
depression we all do go through doubt
and then moments in your life where it's
really difficult and you're trying to
figure out what the your path is going
to be its hardest but stephannie now
we're talking about this before the
podcast starts that that is what makes
you a person and those difficult moments
are what build your character show me a
great man who's the son of a great man
that's what we're saying these kids that
are born billionaires your your your
never going to be a self-made person you
have a backup trust for your backup
trust for your trust and your man I'm
fascinated by martial arts I'm
fascinated by comedy I'm fascinated by
many many different things I don't
understand when people say they're bored
because if I had the time to live a
hundred lives I'd be speaking different
languages I'd be living in different
countries I would I would try a number
of different careers because I think
there's a lot of unbelievably
fascinating puzzling complex things that
you could study in this world that's
just me and my personality but that's a
personality also that have cultivated
over years would you like that as a kid
- well I was involved in martial arts
very early and I think that is one of
the things that motivated me to explore
difficult tasks because through
difficult tasks you learn an incredible
amount about yourself and you through
through the fire of competition you get
to understand you get to understand
motivation you get to understand the
resistance that you have inside your
mind - doing hard work you get to
understand the rewards of discipline
like you don't truly appreciate
relaxation unless you've worked hard and
that is the yin and the yang of life and
I've said this to to the point of people
getting sick of it but
one of the worst decisions a man can
make I can only speak for men obviously
is to be comfortable I don't think you
should try to be comfortable I think
what you should try to do is try to earn
comfort and if you if you can get a day
off where you you you've worked hard and
you've accomplished goals that day off
will be so sweet when I work hard and I
sit in front of TV I enjoy the [ __ ] out
of it I put my feet up I have a nice
drink you know I enjoy my the three airs
that knits your back or something you
have one of those you really look great
right right now I don't use it that much
though honestly I'm more of a workaholic
than I should be probably if the balance
was I probably should relax more than I
do but I never feel like I earned it but
that's not part of the reason why when I
do feel like I earned it I can enjoy it
it's because I am more connected to the
idea that I need to accomplish things
and to and it's not not like for anybody
else's benefit other than my own or
anybody else's approval other than my
own I just when I have a task whether
it's today I'm going to write a thousand
words you know or two thousand or
whatever the number is if I don't do
that I know I'm not I write things down
like I'll write down a list of things
that get accomplished that day and if I
don't accomplish that I'll get sick like
I'll it'll drive me crazy if I can't
fill out that list that drives me nuts
you know but that's what led me to be a
championship-level martial artist that's
what led me to achieve the it's like
that it's the reinforcement of those
goals like understanding that that you
can achieve those goals it's going to be
difficult you're going to push through
the difficulty and then you're going to
understand what difficulty truly is and
how much of it is just mental how much
of it is just in your mind this
adversity - - difficult task or -
struggle you know and a lot of people
have that they're scared they're scared
of complications they're scared of
failure failure is a big one that people
are afraid of but failure is one of the
most important things you could ever
have as far as like the motivation to do
things differently one of the reasons
why I think that I'm good at friendships
and relationships is because I failed at
them in the past one of the things that
I'm good at comedies because I bombed on
stage one of the reasons why I'm good at
war
is because I've been a worker in the
past and I know the feeling of failure
the feeling of of shame of being like a
weak non motivated lazy person it's a
weak feeling it's a you don't respect
yourself you know and I have this phrase
that I use all the time to people to try
to motivate people I say that be the
hero in your own movie pretend that if
your life was a movie and your life
started now what would the hero do what
would the person that you respected what
would the person that you admire person
that inspires you what would they do
we'll do that and if you do that you
slowly build momentum you like today I
did what I wanted to do today I started
a class in yoga I did this I did all
these things that I was saying I wasn't
going to do and now I feel momentum and
momentum is a very important point in
people's lives that's why some folks
don't like to take days off because they
feel like they're losing momentum and
they sort of have to restart the wheel
up again after a vacation you know and
there's a lot of folks that live life on
a cushy cloud of marshmallows and bullsh
and then one day something goes wrong
and I mean that's why spoiled kids are
so sad like a spoiled young boy is one
of the saddest things ever a young boy
that becomes a man and can't take care
of himself and his dad has to keep on
rescuing him his dad has to keep on
bailing them out of situations and
giving them money I've met guys like
that and that is a crippling affliction
when they don't have the character
themselves to be able to get by in life
they constantly need someone to help
them and bail them out even as a grown
man I've met guys in their 40s that
still need help from their parents I'm
like what the man you're never going to
get it right because somewhere along the
line they didn't face enough of the
adversity to realize that there's
sometimes you just got to get up and get
you done there's some times we have to
pull yourself up and you have to push
forward even if you want to stay in bed
and if you don't do that you just keep
calling on your daddy and your daddy
keeps rescuing you
you never develop those tools you never
develop that ability to recognize what
you're doing wrong with your life
because you're you're soft you go to
cushiony you got a safety net a safety
net for your safety net if you had a kid
obviously do have a kid but say if you
had like a 20 year old and he just took
doper or a wakin bakes and doesn't get
anything done he's just always like
I was friends and playing video games
and he's just a loser I wish there was a
way you could show someone like that
like I know that you're getting some
comfort and satisfaction I just laying
around doing nothing eating getting fat
but your life would feel better and
richer if you had a goal you chase that
goal you accomplished some things you
would get this boost of confidence you
get this boost to self-esteem like
whatever it is that you're going to do
maybe you're in a drawn comic books
maybe you're into nah but making pottery
or sculptures or but fine whatever that
is and pursue that instead of doing
nothing like the people that are doing
nothing those are the real people look
doing something might be as simple as
like that Alex Honnold guy he just
climbs rocks but he's world-class rock
Twila it's something but it's also a
goal of his and he's also the best at it
yes yeah but those people who smoke pot
all day Angela those are so the guys who
hate on Joe Rogan for being in shape you
know I'm saying are being disciplined or
get on Kevin Hart's Instagram and to
hate on you no I'm saying cuz they don't
it's their own insecurities I see what
you're saying
but I would assume they would get
motivated by seeing other people do
something with their lives like that
should be motivating not yeah but is
your you up if you grew up with losers
and you're around a bunch of people yeah
attitude especially if it's in your
household mmm I was very lucky that both
my mom and my stepdad there now they're
not they're the least hater people I've
ever met my life they're just not haters
in any way like if someone's doing well
though I was like wow look at this guy
or like Wow look at her Wow look at him
there was never any hate in my house in
terms of other people's success but if
you grew up with a dad and your dad's
like yeah these all these rich [ __ ]
just you think she's a badass in this
but you know these people that look at
other people's success instead of saying
wow look I did a lot of work like the
way I'm a successful person but the way
I look at Kevin Hart he exhausts me you
know or the rock those guys exhausted me
I'm like Jesus Christ like I feel lazy
next to those guys like they do so much
like those guys are so
Oh overbearingly ambitious you know but
some people they see that and they
compare themselves and they don't like
it so they get started getting really
shy and it's like a natural feeling to
try to chip away at that person and the
worst people that you know are the
people that don't have a good self judge
that everything they do is awesome those
never grow anywhere right that's a huge
issue with comedy when you run into
people that have a terrible comedy sets
but think they did great
like we would always Greg Fitzsimmons
and I would always talk about that with
like open mic errs like there's people
that hear phantom labs like they think
they're doing great and they have this
delusional self opinion where everything
they do is awesome and they don't know
why they're not successful already they
don't know why they're not famous and
those people I believe I mean it's from
sort of a weird narcissistic way you
could look at it this way that those
people are there to teach you this is
the consequences of not feeling that
awful feeling when you fail I was
talking to BER a couple weeks ago he did
a set at The Comedy Store and I saw part
of it it was he was killing and then I
ran into him in the hallway and I go out
man main room show was great right and
he goes half up at the end though I
tried to hang in there too long the last
bit bomb like he was just it was a
rotten atom that the last bit like he
goes I've hung in there too long I
should have got off it a bit before that
like but you know when I was in there he
was killing you know but that wasn't in
his mind the success was not in his mind
that was like okay whatever that
happened at the end don't do that again
right right but that's why he's Bill
burr that's why he's really good when
you're alone with your thoughts you get
an idea of what your thoughts actually
are if you live your life just acting
constantly on the momentum of other
people's expectations of you wanting to
be liked by these other people you can
run into a trap and you you you set up a
life that you didn't really want you're
you're you're trapped in this situation
where you have a mortgage
you've got credit card bills you got
student loans you have to pay you have a
bunch going on you have to continue to
feed and all that and especially if you
have a family and you have to feed them
oh my
goodness then you're fully locked in you
can't take any chances whatsoever and
oftentimes people make the mistake of
getting stuck and it is just a tactical
mistake just like it would be a mistake
if you got stuck on a video game just
like it would be a mistake if you
followed a map incorrectly and you get
stuck in the woods your life is
certainly some sort of a journey it's
certainly some sort of a journey and we
have to all be aware that when we're
making journeys we're not going to
always make the right steps and
sometimes you have to back up and try
again and if you're in a position where
you can't back up and try again
you've trapped yourself and the system
will set out honey pots for people to
get trapped in the system will set out
the ideas of retirement the ideas of the
golden years providing you benefits
providing you a healthy work environment
why well because they want people to
work for them
they don't want people to realize their
own dreams and escape but those of us in
the ass you got to hire more people and
train them and they want to set it up so
that you stick around stick around some
sort of an unsatisfying world it's up to
you to see that video game problem to
see that issue as it comes up on the map
known I think this is a right turn to
see all the problems that could
potentially lay in front of you and
calculate your your future and then also
look around all the people that didn't
do it and look at the misery that
they're in and learn that you don't want
to be like them and then look at the
people that are have kind of taken
chances and navigated their way what do
they do differently than you
what would objectivity do they have that
maybe you lack what insight into their
own mistakes are they willing to delve
into that you're not that you step back
and go you know I don't don't I just
don't want to look at myself that
closely but the person who's able to
look at themselves the closest it's
going to get the more rational results
one of the things that's causing this
funk that people are in is that we're
living our lives many of us at least in
these very unfulfilled ways where you're
going to this office with artificial
light and you're doing something you
don't want to do all day long and then
you get home and you're tired and on top
of that you're eating you're eating
potato chips and you're drinking soda
and your body is just like what in the
is this we're supposed to be out in the
fields we're supposed to be walking up
hills we're supposed to be looking for
animals or gathering vegetables
we're supposed to be doing all these
things that our bodies designed to do
we're supposed to be in nature
yeah and nature is like a medicine like
it literally is a medicine to you like
people people that go you don't have to
go hunting you don't have to go fishing
just go hike man just go hike up to the
top of a mountain and look out you know
there's a reward that you get from that
that is intensely like soul filling just
like something about like when I was in
Colorado and there was this this area of
Boulder we drive up one of these roads
and there was this area where you could
park and it was this incredible view man
these people just Park and just go out
there and just look but you get there in
your parking you go
because you would see you're literally
seeing the Continental Divide these
snow-capped mountains in July yeah in
July it's covered with snow because
those mountains don't give a fective one
thing that we are we're an animal but
we're also the next stage of animals
where we're aware of who we are and we
contemplate our existence and when you
contemplate your existence in you're an
intelligent life-form you should always
be seeking to improve if you're always
seeking to improve the thing that you
look at it like what has brought me the
most positive results so it's kindness
its kindness friendship the the
connection with human beings on a very
positive level where you like build up
like a trust and you you have a warmth
and friendship and you root for each
other and you you sharing each other's
bounty and you you build to get you know
that we all know inherently in our in
our heads that kindness is like one of
the best gifts you can bestow another
human being whether it's giving them
food and they don't have any or helping
them out or hooking them up or doing
something to help them just or being
around them and complimenting them
whatever the fit is we know that
inherently that feels great and we know
it and we know that that's the next we
have to figure out how to use our
resources together so we can be like
that all the time I think it's always
about doing what you actually want to be
doing with your life as far as if you
have an inner creative expression to get
out and there's a lot of people that we
always wanted to be singers and they
just for whatever reason never pursued
it yeah so they just sing around their
house and you always wonder what could
have been if we just try to be a singing
that's one form of that decade bum you
out that's one form of a road block in
your life the the depressed feeling that
you didn't try you didn't try to reach
your potential hmm you didn't go after
what is intriguing to you like we all
have almost like a beacon that pulls us
in a certain direction some people it's
nursing some people its construction and
architecting a parent fan people for
some for us it was standeth yeah it's
really simple yeah and it's like there's
there's a something the happiness that's
involved in pursuing your your inherent
desires is the unavoidable thinkwell all
you have to do is find a career yes all
you have to do is find a group but I
guarantee you there's one out there that
you really really want it
yet the ideas like I would be famous
there that's what I was going to say
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because see Sadie asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did Joe say
that had the biggest impact on you what
change you're gonna make in your life
for business after watching this video
please leave in the comments I'm gonna
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to Tuan nuyen
thank you so much you're picking up a
copy of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
the idea that we would literally on a
gigantic organic spaceship you know
that's just too tough butts too crazy to
think you know it's so much easier to
think about Tiger Woods and what was
Jesse James thinking and it's so much
easier to distract yourself with you
know who wears this dress better in
honest magazine 76% say this girl you
know itself I think as human beings we
have we're in a weird sort of an
adolescent stage of evolution and we
have these incredible technical and
technological capabilities and this is
insane ability to communicate with
people all over the world and this
insane ability to exchange information
but we're still we're still trapped in
this monkey body we still have these
monkey instincts and we work like
incredible hot hours and enough you see
kids in school now they have insane
amounts of homework if they're training
you to be a goddamn your own I mean you
you work all day in school and then come
home you have hours and hours of
homework three and four hours of
homework tonight
so the point where you're just accustom
to like doing things you don't want to
do and and then you're gonna take that
and you're going to go to college and
you're going to work on it there and
eventually you're going to get a job and
that job is gonna require hours and
hours of your day and to the point where
you don't have time to think about the
space you don't have time to to think
about if there's some sort of a weird
connection between every human being on
the planet every single action that you
do in is life itself to really just live
sort of a gigantic mathematical equation
stupid czar and other neckties fall to
the average person all those thoughts
there's no room for those when you have
to get out for work in five hours and
your baby's crying and you know you got
to get gas
there's all sorts of different issues
that people that have that keep them
from thinking about the real ears and
aspects of the blind this or this life
is incredibly bizarre JBS Haldane
that in fact not only in the world
stranger than you suppose is stranger
making hands close and it really ends
when you start getting into like the you
start getting into quantum physics and
you know the idea of particles and super
positions where they can exist in motion
and we still at the same time and then
there's subatomic particles that blink
in and out of existence exists to the
places at the same time on what is you
know it's too much it's too crazy in
order to be you to take care of your
mortgage in order for you to be a good
neighbor and show up for the homeowners
association meeting on Tuesday night and
and gossip with the neighbors what who's
losing their house there's too many
variables it's too much saying things
going on and people gravitate toward
stupid mean English because it's easy to
absorb and because it jives well with
our multi instincts you know the Large
Hadron Collider doesn't get nearly as
much weight in the news you know there's
there's a bunch of just 10,000
scientific for making black holes
significant that that's not getting
that's not getting the news you know
that luckily nearly as much attention
we're so strange they would like to
moving we have with the whole human race
is like a goddamn Coen Brothers movie
there's a certain amount of programming
that the media does you know I mean
especially if you watch like stuff like
Fox News so there's a certain amount
where they're sort of conditioning
people to think a certain way but for
the most part it's what people are
interested in
you know I think like the really deep
scary stuff is is to be daunting for a
lot of people there's something about
people that it's like they don't want to
know what's behind the door they don't
want to know what's outside it's too
scary they want to control their micro
world you know and that's why people
like you know having a small group of
friends and living in a small community
and you know and they like to know their
environment and when you get into really
crazy building wonnum physics and you
get into the universe and infinity the
idea of an infinite universe perhaps not
even just one universe but infinite
numbers of universes which is too nuts
it's too crazy to think that up love you
literally goes on forever there is no
room you step outside your house and
there is no you can go you can make a
straight line from your head to a star
that's 14 billion light years away
that's that's the same that's one of the
things that hits you when you do
mushrooms you know if you specially
doing a large dose you you you start
realizing that there's no ground there's
no up and nose-down
you're like in the middle of this and if
there's no there's no edges you know
just goes it goes forever and you're
like you just like right there you're
right there swimming in this Universal
soon
[Music]